siguiendo El ejemplo de las mujeres de
Irán estas manifestantes en la capital
griega se cortaron el pelo en protesta
por el estricto código de vestimenta del
régimen para las mujeres se unen a un
movimiento que se inició después de que
Max samini de 22 años falleciera tras
ser detenida por la policía de la moral
y de anillo
me estoy cortando el pelo porque muchas
de mis hermanas en Irán van a morir
Quizás mañana por culpa del jillaf y yo
no lo quiero y lo odio y no quiero
seguir a este régimen terrorista y
dictatorial
[Aplausos]
es un sentimiento del que se han hecho
eco la diáspora iraní en protestas por
toda Europa el sábado cientos de
personas acudieron a esta manifestación
en Berlín donde algunas manifestantes
dicen que casi corrieron la misma suerte
Trágica que a mini
una situación similar cuando tenía 16
años tuve suerte de que no me parcheran
la cabeza pero he vivido la misma
violencia y no vamos a permitir que esto
vuelva a ocurrir en cualquier parte del
mundo no queremos eso
junto a los retratos de amín y las
manifestantes en Suecia mostraron fotos
de otras supuestas víctimas del régimen
iraní este
régimen debe irse por todas las masacres
que hicieron en 40 años en Irán
intentamos llegar a los políticos de
Suecia y de otros países es lo único que
podemos hacer aquí
[Aplausos]
mientras que las protestas se
intensifican en Irán en el vecino Irak
decenas de personas inundaron las calles
de hervir la muerte de Armenia ha tocado
la fibra sensible de estas manifestantes
muchas de las cuales proceden de la
parte iraní del kurdistán la región
natal de